just over a week since a furious bird's
nest was elected president and many
people they're getting out right there
the birds are getting out people are
still very afraid because it's not just
civil liberties being threatened it's
also shiny things the Donald has
promised to tax imports from China from
China what you could
Wow great raise the price of the iPhone
not to mention his plan to ban all
iPhones that aren't white this this
potential fifty to ninety seven dollar
increases of course most concerning to
liberals since many Trump supporters
prefer to communicate through Illuminati
fluoride brain waves so comedians how
else might Trump's presidency affect the
new iPhones James Davis now you can grab
Syria by the all right
please don't do that right now Dan Leary
it works a lot better than you expected
in the red states all right
what Arielle he'll bring back the
headphone jack and suddenly everyone
will love him yeah that's all he's got
to do that's all you're gonna do is put
the headphone jack back we're below